hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play don't
starve okay we got no time to waste here
we're in a good situation we got food
and stuff on there a lot of good
suggestions from the last round you guys
said that I needed to put the gnomon
size machine but then some of you guys
said that that was taken out and that's
no longer in play either way I know what
I need to find now I need to find things
like this box thingy this may control
the polarity of the whole universe I
need to find the other pieces of this
puzzle and I'm currently in a new area
because I jumped through that wormhole
there but not in a new world as you guys
corrected me on that so what I need to
do is I need to continue exploring the
world like stop setting up base camp in
one location um when the Wolves come you
guys told me that when the full moon
shows up wolves you're gonna try to
murder me so um in order to do survive
that I'm gonna need to try to keep as
much as possible but I've got plenty of
food like more than enough food hello
Turkey what are you doing did you just
jump in that berry bush you're stupid
Turkey alright whatever I'm not gonna
question him I got plenty of food more
than enough to get me through the day um
should be fine there I'm finding much
more on the way and what I gotta do is I
got just I just gotta keep I just keep
swimming walking shoveling murdering
innocent animals either way I got to
keep doing it so we need to find oh crap
ah crap this whole thing is like a
peninsula I've been going the wrong way
alright let's get back on the road I
don't think they'll woo oh okay oh I see
oh that's where the wormhole led me okay
it just went down alright so I've got a
lot to explore I've gotta find the rest
of the pieces but I don't know if there
are multiple locations for them I don't
know if they're like blah blah blah
I don't know I really don't know so
yummy on that one I'll let my science
machine behind so I can't make like a
straw I wanted to make a bunch of
bedroll so that I could like live
through the night or just sleep through
the night and not have to worry about it
I'm just covering the rest of the
darkness to make sure that there's
nothing hiding in there I hear something
oh that's a bee's nest nevermind there's
nothing here
as total emptiness just like my soul all
right
there's nothing here let's carry back on
the road but it's almost nighttime so
I'm going to have to get something but I
want to make some progress cuz I can
make a fire anywhere to make a fire
anywhere and do anything ever I want my
inventory is full though probably not a
good thing
hello dick look at that dead guy what a
loser
Hey I also learned in playing another
game that you can in fact um resurrect
yourself if you die if you activate a
sacrificial altar you can do fine there
hon I can't see the bottom why would you
need to whatever nothing in here makes
sense but anyway I should be able to get
back to my base camp right here-ish it's
not too far away but I won't make it
tonight well I mean I could make it
tonight I could just make a torch I
might be smart I'm probably losing a lot
say let me just finish off these these
are gonna spoil anyway so eat them Adam
Adam let me make a torch portable I
suppose put that in my hand hole and
here we go so now we can make it back to
camp
get to the science machine berries got
to get salt to berries you can and
apparently I can light whole force on
fire with this but I haven't tried that
myself what is that pick up an eye bone
what knack is an eye bone why do I want
an eye bone grass you didn't doing me
any good that is an iPhone it's looking
at me no kidding alright let's get back
on the road we can move around now
what's over here
what is this glowy's this must be
something special like I've seen these
glowy parts around it must be something
special for the sake of going the wrong
way well let's cut through the forest
anyway huh what's the worst that could
happen what's the worst thing could
happen yeah nothing I'm losing a bit of
sanity but this torch is helping me out
a bit I just can't see very much awkward
that well open Chester what what what
what what is that
why are you you're like a little puppy
with your tongue Oh into puke ah
you're adorable all right off to come
back for that later
oh damn adorable okay anyway um kept
hard there okay I'm like what
hahaha no what's your life I got put it
back in
oh good who was that what was what I
don't know it was dark I couldn't see
anything or anyway let's stop being a
giant baby about it and now we can
continue on exploring ocean over there
but I want to see where this road goes
I've gone up it before at some point but
I don't remember if I saw anything hey
is he following me do I have my own
portable chest now that's awesome hey
little boredom a little chest it's gonna
carry all my stuff ain't you boy I'm not
gonna put anything important in him just
in case he runs away or dies give me
that flower my flower bee you back off
oh no oh don't you bid wah whoa don't
you bud at me
Hey look another wormhole should we go
in heck yes
Willy all chesty broad can check the car
can't go Jessie follow me oh oh oh this
is not good I'm in the middle of a swamp
I do not love going in this one let's go
back ah
Oh little girl will Alou I'm guessing it
drops your sanity because he said that's
not a same thing to do well pick a
flower you big baby pick a flower and
feel all better look at chesty I know
little boy who's my little girl whose
mom buddy you are you are Chitti
oh my buddy chesty can I give you a
bearer to eat no you will lead the way
I'm glad I wandered around in the dark
that was awfully nice walk to butterfly
ah I need to carry this axe cuz I need
to chop things in face when I see them I
also realized that things file pretty
quickly when they're cooked for some
reason when they're raw they don't spoil
as quickly especially carrots um but
berries kind of do but when they're
cooked for some reason they spoil a lot
quicker at least that's my experience
I'm not sure if that's correct but
whatever all right so what I'm looking
for is something that I don't know about
what it's a it's kind of like this box
and I got
or melty puddles he'll melt it together
I don't know what these things do
it is like these magical devices that I
have no idea what they're for huh I
don't know I don't know I know there's a
spider nest not go near that or maybe I
should maybe it's got a secret thingy
typically what did I hear I don't hear
anything
do you hear something oh no it might
have been something nearby something
important I do not know
hello my alone here must I do everything
myself fine face me and confess your
crimes
hey is the day getting longer
oh my dial up on the top right there it
looks like my day has grown a bit longer
and it looks like I'm gonna be trapped
on a peninsula again Virge I'm not doing
well on the exploration front I'm
actually doing quite poorly it's a good
thing I'm so awesome anyway my nice
beers that I probably need to shave off
because it's driving me insane
somehow like why would having a beard
make you drop your sanity I have no idea
eat keep stuff your face all right he'll
add butter okay that's just being nice
and peaceful to all of the creatures in
the forest and that way we don't have to
murder anyone what is that you hear that
what is that I hear it on the right side
yeah I hear that what is that pop it on
the left and right
what is that I hear it from the right
now what is it wow what is that
hi Jesse how was it the phlegm out for
those the Wolves where are those Jesus
get out of here I don't want any so
there you go
oh my go oh yeah yeah I got to build a
wall or something this is not good
that's not good that's not good what do
I do
Jesse help me please help me I need to
find some pigmen pikmin actually do help
you so I need to find them where are
they I have no idea where I could find a
Pigman oh I'm so boned do they ever let
go or am I just gonna die I think I'm
just gonna die but then again I always
like to take the pessimistic route to
the things like this go I go I go away
don't even try the chesty he's too tough
for you put a little piece all right I
seem to be going towards a dead end baby
are they finally gonna leave me alone oh
this looks good yeah let's go in here it
seems great oh these are the graves I
dug up that's right this is where I lost
my sanity before so that's all just a
peninsula so no need to go up there
chesty did you are you okay chesty are
you okay dusty are they bothering you oh
don't give them the second thought they
can't do anything they're just dying to
she's you're okay you're okay you'll be
fine
are they ever gonna give up it's getting
late I need to make a fire I kind of got
things chasing after me there's some way
that I could fight those oh no I don't
even have a spear hi bye Jessie stop
beating up on him you let him alone you
leave him alone I'll beat you up
I'll get the bird thingy to come fight a
man kill that kill that stop beating up
chesty what did he ever do to you
leave justy alone okay I think he I
think he took the bait I think you went
up hey my science machine
what do you know cool anyway I need to
refine some stuff I need to refine
goodies and doodads and thingamabob errs
and I need to drop this chesty hold this
for me thank you
y'alright you don't look so good oh
you'll be just fine okay let's build a
campfire
yeah bar chop it down I need to survive
the night is shorter too it's like the
day is getting longer I guess the
seasons changing and that means that I
get more some Tom Tom don't remember
what powers okay um let's see
damn it I don't want to leave things
with Chet because I feel like he's about
to die but I guess if he does die he's
gonna blow up and drop all the stuff
anyway so I guess I just leave him with
stuff cuz I got and see I've got a
couple really interesting stuff like a
gem and a frazzled wires and boards and
I've got got stuff I just need to find
out what to do with it all maybe this
pick that uh you fix the eye bone of
some sort you guys let need to let me
know in between the parts if I've got
like enough stuff to make something
important and you're like hey stupid
we're doing well no I
your is no dumb I'm the greatest okay
that's you by the way those you gnomes
all right so I got my science machine
here I need to refine smooth down any
more boards let's take a lot of wood and
I don't know why they shouldn't take
that much
all right okay Chester sleeping on look
at him okay so now that I have this um I
don't have enough for an alchemy engine
I need more wood it can get some from
these stumps here not enough I just put
some wood in the fire like an idiot
don't know what's wrong with me so dumb
whatever whatever whatever whatever
why does not only give one plank why why
does it look like oh gosh the full moon
is coming does that mean more of those
wolves thingies I don't like those wolf
things I mean I can run away from them
but I still don't like them what
whatever
my life is just pain and get one more
from the stump and that should be enough
to make the wood I don't have enough
stone no oh yes I do what am i time out
I was looking at my flint sorry I'm an
idiot and rambling to myself some people
say I talk too much that's probably true
but I have this innate ability like a
lot of you know me and you know that I
have this really really innate ability
to just ramble on for hours and hours
and hours okay I'll just put this here
make it sort of us I mean I know my base
camp is like over here on the wrong side
but I got the alchemy engine here anyway
so um what I need
you just find more stud yes I need a
spear that's what I need
beer look something to actually fight in
this way see some breakfast some
breakfast
mmm that's good right there we go
carrots actually increased more health
than normal but I'm not exactly worried
about that right now
the berries get some fresh ones get
these look at the logs from when I cut
this down a long time ago friendly just
hey you got a white there Thursday are
you wait there testy don't die please
dear God do not die I have all of my
precious materials in you I do not need
you to be dead I need you to be living
and perky and happy ring ring ring why
do you need so much grass for stuff
grass seems like something that you
really don't need a lot for but I'm just
hitting up all the targets with all this
grass great I love it okay gotta find
these materials and then I'm gonna head
well alright I'm not even gonna get that
one screw that I didn't want it anyway I
in a mugger okay now we got enough scrap
to last up a while yeah we do but let's
pick more on the way also I got a bunch
of leaf petals that are just kind of
spoiling on me why don't we photos why
do I want to eat leaf petals they'll
don't do it anymore
oh don't attack the beehives bees will
leave you perfectly well alone unless
you attack them and then like 90 of them
will pop out and murder your face off I
know this from personal experience ah
man there's gotta be something here I'm
it's like I'm walking in this constant
peninsula everywhere no matter where I
go I can't seem to find a way out
I guess if I took that wormhole that I
took before I could like maybe go
through the swamp but I really would
rather not go through the swamp right
now cuz I don't have any armor I'm stuck
with this backpack at the moment yeah
but I suspect that I'm going to have to
anyway oh well I'm an adventurer a brave
gentlemen of the 18th century 19th
century I don't know when this takes
place but I'm a brave gentleman
nonetheless with a spear can I make a
gun can I do that there's nothing here
Ricca frack
maybe there's something down here
probably not a maybe you never know run
away little bunny I'm a scary man what
is that what was that you guys hear that
it was like some tribal drums what was
that what was that yeah probably nothing
whole place is getting to me I get my
mind goes soft and I've already wasted
half the day just wandering around doing
nothing let's at least get back on the
road so we go be a little bit faster
yeah I'm such a disappointment aren't I
I try and try and once I actually know
what I'm doing akin it would anymore
little ways do dah dah dah dum dum
that's probably a peninsula over there
too so I'm not even gonna try that what
I need to do is I need to go farther
south cuz I have enough on materials to
do fine on my own in chesty is safe by
my machines so I just need to keep
adventuring on my own I should probably
do is I should probably dump some tools
that way instead of a backpack I can
keep actually that's probably a good
idea that's probably a really good idea
I need some armor if I'm going to be
fighting things so what I need to do is
I need to get some stone some more stone
from these places and then just start
collecting everything that I need and I
could use some gold too so it's mine
this is mine this is mine huh this is
mine this is mine thank you
mine mine mine everybody do it mine mine
mine mine this is gonna take forever
hey forever oh there's my old campsite
all right I'm just gonna fast forward a
bit here so you guys don't need to worry
about that I'll pick it up one time in
the morning and I catch up on everything
that I need to get be right back good
morning everybody welcome back to the
game okay our beards getting a little
bit longer but we've got a ton of gold
and a ton of stone and lots of stuff
that we need to do I need to get back to
the machine so that I can readily get
everything that I need I need to build
some armor I believe that you can either
make wood armor or stone armor I'm not
sure I can't remember maybe I can make
gold armor I have no idea really but I
need to find out soon so let's get to
that machine gotta be something light
right gonna be some logs suit okay log
suit okay I'll make a log suit as soon
as I cut down some more wood which I
need to do like right now a log suit
should provide me ample protection from
the forces of nature that are trying to
murder my face many many many things are
trying to murder my face I don't know
why I have such a pretty face I don't
know why they would want to murder it
maybe they're just jealous of me I would
be jealous of me I'd be so jealous of me
aah Oh Oh aah no my ax nothing to worry
about
ok let me just clean up the stumps my
shovel way over here
my inventory is to fill I hope chesty is
still there if Jesse's not there I will
be so mad cuz I didn't look how we
didn't look for chesty y'all good
chesty still there her Chester I'm gonna
call him chesty still thanks jester okay
anyway I need to make one login suit and
hire log in suit and blocking okay so to
do this I need you to carry this carry
this and you need to carry I need you to
carry
I'll take those stale pedals cuz they're
good fuel not for eating but for you
ticked up nah I don't need a picked fork
let me just drop it I can drop the tools
I don't need them I can always make more
if I really really want some that there
and then drag this down here drag this
down here drop that on the ground I can
just leave stuff on the ground right it
won't make a big deal right alright then
I can just put the gold in there and
drop that and I'm good to go cuz I can
put this on now and I'll leave the
backpack here alright let me do one last
thing to make sure that I don't have
anything that I need to nothing that I
can do to protect the my seal apparently
not so let's get to it
alright so we're exploring down and
we're going to go to the swamp now is
all what this is all about we're trying
to get stuff so that we can go down to
the swamp and then explore around the
swamp for another item unless I have the
special items required I do not know
like I have a lot of special items I
just don't know if they're what I need
run little bunnies I'm a warrior with my
hot beard log suit and spear I'd be
afraid of me okay what I'm working for
this wormhole or that wormhole this
one or that one which one more was it oh
maybe it was always that wormhole cuz I
one led to there that one just popped
over no no no yeah this is the one I'm
looking for I'm looking for this one
common common I am under control
Oh Google run away run away go away
wolven I should try to get him to bite a
beehive or something possibly I can do
that
cuz if I just start walking around the
Beehive eventually you might
incidentally attack it then I wouldn't
be good
ok here we go in to the wormhole let's
get up put your health up things we can
kind of stale there but that's ok still
good food Blore it alright in the swamp
bring it on everybody what you got what
you got I'm picking this up giving it
reads what do I need reads for I have no
idea ah ah oh what the hell is that what
ha ha was a tentacle why this isn't good
huh there it is again
ok let's screw that I'm getting out of
the swamp if that's what's waiting for
me I'm going over here for this gold
mine over here y'all can screw
yourselves for all I care wow there's a
lot of material over here alright
anyway let's follow the road until we
can find something dastardly and
evil-looking then we can make a portal
to get out of this place because that's
the primary objective of this whole game
suspicious dirt fire animal track animal
track a woah woah woah woah woah woah
what is that what is that what is that
things are getting Oh metal potato
thingy and a farm what oh there's my new
home Oh found my new home but what the
heck are these things seriously what are
these ah that bees there last that was
this is not my home
this is not gonna be my home holy crap
no no no I say no to that good thing I
might log see
Gado dime my logs it actually does
prevent like a lotta damage okay but
this is cool anyway because I have seeds
with me like right here with me I can
actually plant them right now I could
plant them I don't know what they grow
into but if I keep my home like
relatively to the south of these guys
I should be fine you know that's it
really cool is that I can I can um I can
pick stuff up like berry bushes and I
think I can plant them in this little
plot here right cuz then I could keep my
own farm going with both like all the
carrots and the twigs and bushes I can
take those grass out of there I can find
grass anywhere I just put some berry
bushes down instead right right ah just
collect all the resources for now cuz
we're running out of time here I'm
probably gonna close up shop here so
anyway we made some good progress we now
got a metal potato thingy um I don't
know why chesty stopped following me but
chesties got all the other stuff so umm
you he's just up here so he's he's not
far away I can see him on the mini-map
right there I could probably there might
be a road in between here I could just
take that either way I can get back to
him no problem so anyway this is going
surprisingly well I might get out of
here soonish so I got a metal potato low
unknown wires a gem um something else
you can review the footage it's baldock
there you can see so let me know if I
got something to make something cuz I
don't really know I'm still a newbie
this as much as I played it myself you
guys got to tell me what to do so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos I've done and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
Oh
ah
bud
you